martin schiller 44 jahre porträtfotograf
einer der profiliertesten seines fachs
sein neuestes buch einziger identisch
studien von eineiigen zwillingen von
drillingen und vierlingen verschiedenen
geschlecht hautfarbe und alter mit dem
alter von siebzig sich noch sehr ähnlich
sehen und andere sind vielleicht nur 20
und sehen sich schon gar nicht mehr so
ähnlich oder zu der zeit lebensphase
nicht ein ich habe fast das gefühl
gehabt dass die älteren zwillinge sich
ähnlicher sehen als sage mal die 70
jährigen zwillinge sehen sich oftmals
ähnlicher als sieht 40 jährigen
zwillinge als ob wird man dann die
gleichheit wiederkommen
im alter das buch al dente ging aus
einem auftrag der zeitschrift national
geographic hervor
seine für ihn typischen close up
porträts macht martin keller seit 15
jahren vor allem die großen us magazine
wie time oder den new yorker drucken
seine arbeiten nicht selten ganzseitig
und oft porträtiert er die erste garde
weltweit bekannter persönlichkeiten
würde
für eine teil- sonderausgabe zu den
olympischen spielen in london lieferte
er diese fotos time magazin fotografiert
und schwarzem stoff auf dem boden vom
vom swimmingpool gelegt und licht der
unter ihnen angebracht unter wasser
lichter und lag dann oben auf dem
sprungbrett und habe seinen grund der
fotografie und deshalb aber eben hin und
her geschwungen für mich das ist die
besten sportler bilder die ich bisher
gemacht habe
nicht nur die prominenz auch solche
motive heizen den fotografen weibliche
bodybuilder auch aus diesen porträts
entstand ein buch
manche sender bilder wie dieses der
tennis bruder breiten sieht so aus als
sei es spontan entstanden
doch für ein gutes foto braucht schüler
manchmal stunden
vorausgesetzt man lässt
ihre merkel war für ein amerikanisches
magazin vergleich
clinton habe ich für den new yorker
fotografiert es hängt immer ganz davon
ab wen ich fotografiert wie viel zeit
ich bekomme mit angela merkel hatte ich
fünf minuten und mit bill clinton 25
minuten
das hängt davon ab wie wichtig es den
leuten ist für dieses magazin zuvor über
vier zu werden wie wichtig die leute
selber sind oder wie viel zeit zu haben
drei fotobände hat martin schoeller
bisher veröffentlicht und längst hängen
seine bilder in den westen foto greven
der wert die berliner galerie camera
work präsentiert gerade die
farbfotografie als eigene kunstform
unter mehr als 100 bildern weltweit
bekannter fotografen sind auch fotos von
martin schoeller wie dieses mit dem
regisseur quentin tarantino ich mache
gerne porträts als ich angefangen habe
war ich mir nicht ganz sicher ein
bisschen dach die fed könnte ich
modefotograf auch sein oder landschaften
oder stillleben aber ich denke porträt
ist das was meine persönlichkeit am
besten entspricht mit menschen umzugehen
ich interessiere mich nicht für mode als
modefotograf muss man wurde verliebt
sein das kann ich von mir nun wahrlich
nicht behaupten und ich denke auch immer
ist als fotograf es am besten sich zu
spezialisieren da schon schwer genug
überhaupt ein gutes foto zu machen ein
gutes porträt zu machen und
deswegen bleibe ich dabei das thema
zwillinge von schiller anfangs nicht
sonderlich reizvoll zwillinge wurden
schließlich schon oft fotografiert doch
je mehr er sich mit ihnen befasste umso
spannender fand in den auftrag jetzt
willigen werden oftmals als eine einheit
behandelt
ich habe von vielen wenigen gehört
diesen zur schule gegangen und keiner
hat sich überhaupt die mühe gemacht die
namen zu lernen weil man sie irgendwo
immer verwechselt hat und diese
gegenüberstellung dass man eben
zwillinge als individuum betrachtet
einzeln fotografiert später
zusammenstellt habe ich glaube ich einer
zwillings fotografie noch nicht gesehen
letzten endes sind martin schäfers
motive unerschöpflich bin nichts ist
faszinierender für einen
porträtfotografen als das menschliche
gesicht